[Music]
[Music]
Game of Thrones season a is right around
the corner and after a two-year way hype
has never been higher there's been a
wealth of information about Season eight
that has a hell of a lot to unpack from
it so I thought I'd put together a list
of everything that we know so far about
the show's return as well as what could
happen in the new series throughout this
video I'll be breaking down all of the
key information that we have as well as
what it could mean for the future based
on theories plot leaks and more there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want to know anything about the
show before it begins and I highly
recommend that you turn off now with
that out the way I'm definition and
let's get into everything we know so far
about season eight of Game of Thrones
okay so the first thing that you need to
know is that the show will return to HBO
on April 14th and run all the way to May
19th in the meantime we have a lot of
teaser trailers that showcase what the
show has to offer the latest more
general teaser that was recently
released by HBO highlighted some of
their upcoming shows whilst it may seem
a bit backwards to do this first it
actually ties into the earlier clips in
the Game of Thrones segment of the
trailer we can see Jon introducing
Daenerys to Sansa at Winterfell it's
clear that Sansa isn't happy that Jon
bend the knee however it does confirm
that the groups are indeed working
together as a coalition to take down the
undead forces that are racing towards
them of course Winterfell has plenty of
revelations for Jon who will not only
discover that he is in fact the heir to
the Iron Throne
but that he has also just had sex with
his auntie yikes
still the family reunion has been long
over to you and there's definitely a lot
to look forward to here when they
finally come back together as one which
ties into the first teaser the first
teaser showcased the recently reunited
Starks made up of Jon Snow San
an area walking through their family
crypt we can hear limitations of their
long deceased ancestors talking about
how John Snow was initially not seen as
a true member of the household before
Ned played by Sean Bean reassures John
that he is a stark just not in name
throughout the teaser John carries a
torch and this confirms that he is in
fact the light bringer you may remember
that Melisandre told the prophecy of the
light bringer who was a legendary hero
that will be reborn in the warrior which
this definitely cements eventually they
reached the end of the crypt and
discovered three effigies made
especially for them as they study them
at the torch blows out and the cold
starts to creep in bran Stark aka the
three-eyed Raven is notably absent from
this and this could potentially be a
vision that he has given them as a
warning or he may be in other lands the
initial teaser that was released showed
ice and fire ravaging the lands and
meeting at the river lands personally I
think that this highlights that there
will be a large battle that takes place
here between the three dragons with the
ice side representing the new white
dragon also this week we saw an influx
of posters for the show with different
characters sitting atop of the Iron
Throne whilst they all seemed pretty
standard on the surface the Jon Snow one
actually has a lot that stands out about
it most notably John is almost in the
exact same position as the ill-fated Ned
Stark is father who we of course know
died in the first season some have
theorized that this could indeed
highlight that John too will be killed
in season eight however others have
noted that Ned seems to be staring down
resigned to his fate whereas John is
defiantly looking up personally I think
that the series will end with John on
the Iron Throne and this similarity
highlights that obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the teasers so far
and if you have any theories about what
could happen in the show make sure you
leave them in the comments below and if
you enjoy this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my entire
breakdown of the plot of Captain Marvel
which will be linked at the end of this
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]